I love maps and I love mountains and I love being on
mountains with a map. So I read with some alarm,
a warning from the Scottish mountaineering association,
telling people to be careful about how they store them campuses.
We carry a lot more magnets right around than we used to,
and that can get you into trouble. It can deflect the needle of your compass,
or in some cases it can reverse the polarity altogether.
So got the trusty compass here, lots of surprising things have magnets in them,
anything with a speaker in it has a magnet.
And you can see just by waving the phone nearby the compass,
you can deflect the needle.
And so if you inadvertently have a magnet in your sleeve or as a fastening,
when your phone and your, you have anywhere near your compass,
you can get pointed in the wrong direction.
And if you store this compass for a long time next to something with a strong
magnet, you could actually reverse the polarity of the compass needle.
But this sort of opened the flood Gates into learning a bit about the
Earth's magnetic field as a whole astronomers don't know a lot about magnetic
fields. It's a running joke that at a conference,
if someone can't think of a question to ask, they ask,
have you considered magnetic fields? So no,
I would not count myself as an expert on magnetic fields.
If you're going out in the Hills and you're going to rely on a compass,
which is a good thing to do, because even if you have a GPS on your phone,
which isn't going to be using the ears magnetic field,
you never know when that might conk out.
So if you ever look closely at a topological map,
like the ones I've got here,
you see in the corner often a little diagram that says, Hey,
be careful here.
What you think of as normal on this map might not match what your compass is.
This is telling you the direction that the compass points is not
necessarily almost never exactly at the true North,
towards the North pole. And so on every corner of every map,
you'll see a little correction that tells you how much you have to correct your
bearings for this particular point on the earth. Yeah.
I can't say that myself I've ever been reliant on that level of detail in my
navigation
plus here in the UK, the deflections are fairly small.
So here you can see three degrees correction East of North,
but in some places,
particularly near the magnetic North pole in the North of Canada,
you can be up by 40 degrees and you definitely don't want to be relying on your
compass without correcting it in that case.
So there are multiple poles on the earth.
There's what we think of as the North pole, you know, where Santa lives,
and this is, this is associated with the rotator patient of the earth.
The earth is spinning on its axis.
That access is actually tilted with respect to the sun,
but we won't worry about that today. So the earth is spinning on the axis,
the axis,
the rotation goes up through the surface of the earth and subject to some
caveats I'm not going to talk about in this video is more or less what we call
the, the geographic North pole that, that the, the maps point to that's.
Pretty much where your finger and thumb are.
Yeah, right, right. About there. Yeah.
Where the pins would go into a globe and.
The pins would go in the globe.
But how would a compass needle know to point at the geographic North or South
pole? In fact,
they don't the magnetic North pole and the magnetic South pole that our compass
is points. Wards are actually in a different place altogether.
And in fact that place actually moves. So to understand what's going on here,
you really have to understand how the magnetic field of the earth is formed in
the first place. Unfortunately, we don't really know,
at least not in the details, it gets very complicated.
But what we do know is that the structure of the interior of the earth has at
its core, just like this plum does a very solid core of solid iron.
And that's surrounded by a sea of liquid iron.
And that makes up about half of the Earth's interior.
So about 3000 kilometers in radius from the center.
And it's this molten iron core that we think is
generating and keeping this magnetic field.
Why would the fact that there's liquid metal suddenly say, alright,
well then you can have a magnetic field.
So now we enter the very complicated field of Magneto
hydrodynamics, where you're putting together equations from fluid dynamics,
like the NAVAIR Stokes equation. And you're pulling together, you know,
the core equations, Maxwell's equations from electromagnetism,
and you put them all together and you try to understand how the behavior of a
conducting fluid in motion through a magnetic field,
what the effects of that will be. So to produce the Earth's magnetic field,
you need three things. First, you need a conducting liquid.
Do you need that liquid to be in motion and not just chaotic motion,
but fairly ordered flows.
And you get that from two processes first convection. Uh, so the,
the core of the earth is extremely hot and so much like Elavil lamp,
it cycles through, up and down and up and down and circulates,
but then it gets complicated because it's also rotating because of the rotation
of the earth.
And so this sets up some very complicated flow patterns.
And then the third really important ingredient you need is a seed magnetic
field. So something has to be there to start with. And once you've got that,
you have a magnetic induction.
So you've got a conductive fluid moving across these magnetic
field lines in this ordered flow.
And when you have a conducting fluid moving across magnetic field lines,
you generate electrical currents,
those electrical currents in turn generate magnetic field lines.
And so you have this self perpetuating system without the motions of the fluid
across these magnetic field lines that we would expect the magnetic field to
just decay away in about 15,000 years. So,
but we it's been there for, for many, many geological timescales.
You can think of the magnetic field of the earth in a very simple
approximation, like a giant bar magnet. And we call that a dipole.
So it's got the North and the South magnetic poles,
and then you've got these magnetic field lines that come out and around and
connect them. And so that's the simple approximation.
And if you drew a line through that,
you get to what we call the geo magnetic North and South pole,
which are exactly opposite. Each other.
The GM magnetic North pole is located slightly off the coast of Greenland.
And that's where you see all of the Aurora and more than lights centered on
that.
Okay.
But what we care about with our compass is the magnetic North pole.
And that has a very practical definition. That's the point on the earth surface,
where if you're carrying a compass,
and if you allow that compass needle to tilt in all directions,
you stood over the magnetic North pole,
the compass needle would point straight down. And that's what we call North.
Yeah.
So when I'm walking around England,
my needle's not like perfectly flat. It's actually always tilting slightly down.
It's always tilting slightly down and it's not necessarily pointing straight to
the magnetic North pole.
It's following whatever the local magnetic field lines are,
which are actually quite complicated. So I've got this map here,
which shows you the world magnetic field model.
This is essentially how much you have to correct your compass bearing
by depending on where you are on the surface of the earth.
So if you're anywhere near the green line, you're doing okay.
And that's where we are up here.
We only have a deflection called the declination of a few degrees elsewhere.
You can get up to 10, 20, 30 degrees,
and that it's not necessarily in a nice North and South pattern in line with,
you know, lines of longitude.
It gets really messy and even more interesting.
The magnetic North pole is not directly opposite the magnetic South pole
either. It gets really, really weird on different parts of the earth.
So I can show you a map of what's called the magnetic anomaly.
You can note one interesting place, which is in here.
This is the Central African Republic of a place called Bungie,
miss the site of the Bungie magnetic anomaly.
And it's a place where you would have no luck with your compass.
It would just be pointing all over the place because the magnetic,
the local magnetic field, they're just going.
What's weird.
Is that in terms of like there's a bunch of mountains with metal in it,
or the actual fundamental core created magnetic field is going weird on us.
We don't know these that cause of the anomaly.
It's probably some combination of crust and mantle
interaction.
Either igneous extrusion material from the mantle has come up and solidified or
perhaps an impact from a meteor, right. Has, has done something to the crust,
but something there locally makes the magnetic field a bit wonky.
Do we know why the way that the magnetic poles turned
out is so non aligned with the geographic poles,
it would seem intuitive that the spinning liquid and everything that's going on
would kind of roughly line up with the rotation of the earth.
I mean, it does. I mean, when you think about it,
they are pretty close to the North and South pole.
We're only talking 10 degrees apart. And in fact,
that's predictable by what we know about fluid dynamics is that the fluid in a
rotating system will set up sort of these columns aligned with the spin axis.
But what gets really interesting is to know that the magnetic North pole isn't
even stable. In fact, it moves around,
we've known it moves around for quite a long time. Um,
but it's moving faster these days it's accelerating.
So it used to be that the magnetic North pole was somewhere in the North of
Canada in the territory that we now call the Nunavut territory,
but it's been racing and accelerating and is now heading at great speed towards
Siberia. Interestingly,
while the magnetic South pole stays more or less where it is.
So that's another illustration that there's some local effect in the fluid flow
underneath the North pole. Um,
something akin to the jet stream that we see in the atmosphere. That's actually,
um, driving the, the change in the magnetic North pole and they can move around.
So for the past 400 years,
we think it was contained more or less within Northern Canada. Um,
but in the past 50 years, it started to move around.
So it was moving around about tens of kilometers a year back and forth.
And in the last 50 years,
it started moving northwards and the past 30 years it's accelerated.
And this year it's now moving at 50 kilometers over the course of the year,
heading towards Siberia.
Stake in the ground or anything like they do at the South pole is that,
is this position marked in any way? And do they have to move the marker?
Yeah, it's marked on maps, but it's not going to be a physical marker,
partly because of how fast it's moving. And partly because, um, the nature of,
of where it is, there's no,
there's no solid ground up there or solid ice that's reliable. Um,
particularly since the Arctic ice is now melting at an accelerating rate. Um,
so no nobody's up there moving markers around, but because of this motion,
normally the,
the magnetic maps are updated every five years and they've actually had to do an
inter cycle sort of emergency update to that because it's moving so fast.
It's not going to affect anybody here using their compass to walk in the,
you know, the Highlands of Scotland,
but it is going to make a difference for anybody relying on the fine details,
particularly up here in the North, uh, Northern latitudes.
I don't know anyone who is more proudly Canadian than you.
How do you feel about Canada potentially losing the magnetic North pole?
Well, I only actually learned that fact today and I do feel a bit sad because I,
I, it was a source of national pride, um, that, that for hundreds of years,
we had the magnetic North pole within our territory. Um, but no,
there's nothing I can do about it. I can't hang on to it.
So this is the neat thing.
The magnetic North pole might be moving around and taking a bit of an excursion
around Northern latitudes.
But we also know that quite regularly on geological timescales,
the whole system flips.
So just like I was talking about my compass reversing its polarity,
the whole magnetic field of the earth,
occasionally slips so that the North pole becomes the South and the South pole
becomes the North.
We don't know why this is again in the details because it's an immensely
complicated scenario,
but we do know that it happens and it happens with great regularity if not
periodicity.
So we know that there have been 183 reversals in the past
83 million years.
And that's a record that we can establish really well,
thanks to geological measurements of the magnetic field,
because we have this really interesting phenomenon that when molten mental
material comes out and solidifies that cooling volcanic rock
retains,
sort of the fingerprints of the Earth's magnetic field direction at that time.
So we go back to our magnetic anomaly map.
You'd actually see here in the mid Atlantic or the mid Pacific that where
material is coming up from the crust and where these tectonic plates are being
pushed apart.
You've got this regular incursion of liquid mantle coming up and
solidifying it's retaining the direction of the magnetic field of the earth as
it swaps back and forth. So on that map,
we've got these stripes of red and blue,
which indicate that the field's been switching back and forth.
What does a flip look like? Again? We don't really know,
so we can do models. Um, and we can do some quite interesting models.
Here's computer models of what a flip might look like done in a supercomputer.
So here's what we think the magnetic field of the earth might look like now.
And so you've got these nice well-defined dipole magnetic field lines coming
out, but a big mess locally towards the surface of the earth.
Some point through a reversal, you might get a situation like this,
where it's just a big mess.
You might have the North and South pole just wandering around.
They might disappear.
You might have more than one pole pop-up chaotically in different places.
The magnetic field of the whole earth might decrease altogether.
We don't really know best estimates are that it might take a thousand
or tens of thousands of years to happen. Um,
some people think it might happen within a human lifetime, does that?
We could see what happened.
Well, it's.
An interesting thing to think about that.
We've seen the magnetic North pole go for a wander.
That wandering seems to be accelerating since we've been making measurements
since about 1840,
there's been a steady decrease in the strength of the magnetic field.
So it's leading some people to think that we might be in the early stages of a
reversal, but whether that happens next year or in the next 10,000 years,
we can't be sure sometimes the magnetic field just goes on a bit of a wobble
called an excursion, but then it comes back to the, the, the normal polarity.
But when it does flip from one end to the other,
we Mark those geological timescales in periods called crumbs.
Is there any reason to think that a reversal of this process is dangerous?
I mean,
it's happened so many times that it feels like it must not be catastrophic.
Yeah. I mean,
it does seem to be quite an alarming thing to happen on the scale of the planet.
Um, but we don't see strong evidence that you sort of, you know,
evidence for mass extinctions in the fossil records are tied closely to these
geological records. Then again,
we also know that some animals use magnetic fields to navigate
by. You have to be concerned about any small perturbation to something as
complicated as our global ecosystem.
We also know that this has happened since the time that humans have been on the
earth. Um, and we don't have any record of catastrophic things happening.
Um, so it could be that it's just such a slow and gentle process that,
um, ecosystems and evolution and everything can sort of keep up with the change.
What we might be concerned about is increased particle radiation.
We know that the magnetic field of the earth protects us from highly charged
particles.
It might be that more cosmic rays are able to reach the ground with a weak
magnetic field,
but the atmosphere itself does a pretty good job of protecting us as well.
So it might be that we just get interesting effects like Aurora seen over
the Galapagos islands or something like that.
It might not be as catastrophic as you might fear.
So of course the next question is what are the magnetic fields like on other
planets? So all of the gas giants,
strong magnetic fields do putter unsurprisingly has the biggest of them all.
And you can actually hear the sound of Jupiter's magnetic field.
If you look at the recordings from the Juno spacecraft,
which reached Jupiter a few years ago.
Uh.
I recorded bow shock as the instrument pass through Jupiter's magnetic field.
So no surprises there, mercury has a weak one,
Venus and Mars don't seem to have any at all.
And the relative strengths is tied to what's happening in the core.
Mars has a solid core. We think no conduction, no rotation.
So that's not going to generate a magnetic field that might go some way to
explaining why Mars has lost the atmosphere.
It used to have magnetic field might have some sort of, uh,
confining action there. But the really interesting one is Uranus.
Uranus is an interesting planet in its own, right?
Because of course its axis of rotation is tilted at 98 degrees to the plane of
the ecliptic,
which since we've been talking about everything being connected to rotation,
what does Uranus's magnetic field look like? And it's a complete mess.
The access of the magnetic field in Uranus is actually tilted at 60
degrees from the axis of rotation.
And what that means is the whole field is tumbling as the planet rotates,
which means that the magnetic field lines detach and then reattach in really
chaotic ways, which means that the,
the planet actually sort of has a strobe effect with its magnetic field that it
opens up and lets charge particles in and then snaps closed again,
opens and closes open closes.
Presumably the sun has a magnetic field.
It does, it's generated in a slightly different way. Um,
but of course it has a very large magnetic field.
We know that it waxes and wanes on a quite regular timescale of 11 years and
that's tied into solar activity and sunspot cycles and we can see the beautiful
magnetic loops that are created from that.
There's still a lot. We don't exactly know like there is like,
it is still one of those sort of mystery subjects. There's lots. We do know,
but there seems like there's lots. We don't know.
Yeah, I think that's correct.
And when you think about what's going into all of this, the very,
very complex interplay between all of the different systems,
the difficulty in understanding what's going on below the surface of the earth,
3000 kilometers below the surface of the earth and making guesswork there,
plus the fact that we've only been making these measurements for a few hundred
years. Um, yeah, I think it's a very, uh, complicated field,
but when I'm sure that it's going to make lots of progress in,
in the near future.
Different from the,
it's not just a scaled up version of that electromagnet is what's called
superconducting magnet. So actually when I applied a,
a current to that elect to that little mini electromagnet with the orange wire
earlier on.